ein polizeieinsatz mit einem toten und
die große frage warum ein video kann
jetzt helfen diese frage zu beantworten
hier sehen sie es geht um einen
großeinsatz in oer erkenschwick vor drei
wochen war das an einem sonntag gefilmt
hier von passanten von menschen die vom
balkon aus alles beobachten und es geht
um den bösen verdacht dass hier einiges
aus dem ruder gelaufen ist ganz ganz
viel schiefgelaufen ist bei diesem
polizeieinsatz und dass das was da
schiefgelaufen ist vertuscht werden so
zähnen eines dramatischen
polizeieinsatzes eines tödlichen
einsatzes in oer erkenschwick
[Musik]
sie kommen unten aus dem eingangs seit
minuten schon kämpft ein großaufgebot
der polizei dort mit einem randalierer
mit diesem mann sascha h 39 jahre alt
polizeibekannt er gilt als
drogenabhängig als gewalttätig auch
jetzt wird er sich heftig gegen die
beamten es sind seine schreibt es sind
die letzten schreie von sascha h wenig
später ist er tot
[Musik]
was passierte in diesem hausflur in
oer-erkenschwick warum starb sascha h
nach diesem polizeieinsatz
die beamten selbst löschten eigene
einsatz videos angeblich nur weil der
festgenommene nackt war tatsächlich weil
vieles beim einsatz schieflief klar ist
längst laufen ermittlungen gegen vier
beamte offiziell heißt es die zuständige
staatsanwaltschaft bochum geht bezüglich
vier weitere einsatzkräfte von einem
anfangsverdacht für eine nötigung aus
bei ihr körpereinsatz übertrieben könnte
sascha h noch leben
die fakten es ist der siebte august als
die polizei in diesen häuserblock
gerufen wird zu einem ehestreit eine
schlägerei die wohnung soll verwüstet
sein der ehemann sascha h soll
festgenommen werden er randaliert die
polizei setzt pfefferspray ein dann
läuft der einsatz aus dem ruder immer
mehr polizei dann schleppen beamten den
nackten mann aus dem aus unterschreibt
150 menschen sehen und filmen diesem
moment anwohner nun sind es zeugen warum
ist sascha h nach diesem polizeieinsatz
gestorben videos wie diese sollen die
wahrheit ans licht bringen
[Musik]